breaking into the Chinese market is
critical to the long-term success of any
International Company consumer spending
in China is set to double by 2030 to
nearly 13 trillion the same amount
Americans currently spend yet many
foreign firms have a hard time
navigating a market as complex as China
when Amazon entered China in 2004 by
acquiring the Chinese shopping site
joyo.com for about 75 million it
believed it could replicate its stunning
success in America unfortunately for
Jeff Bezos his foray into East Asia
didn't go as planned Amazon shut down
its Chinese domestic e-commerce
Marketplace in 2019. yet since Elon Musk
set up a Tesla gigafactory in Shanghai
demand for his electric cars has been
booming
China was responsible for producing half
of Tesla's cars worldwide in 2021 China
rocks my game you know energy in China
is great people there are there's like a
lot of smart hard-working people selling
electric cars and selling everyday goods
are obviously two different Industries
yet one can argue that you can make a
comparison because both are American
companies that try to make inroads in
China but adopted very different
strategies despite entering China early
Amazon struggled to compete against
teamall.com owned by Alibaba Group which
has since grown to become the country's
leading e-commerce platform Amazon's
market share fell from 15 in 2011 to
less than one percent by 2018. nor could
Amazon China compete with the other
dominant player jd.com part of the
problem was that Amazon failed to
innovate in China when Alibaba
introduced its own payment platform
alipay in which people could pay
digitally for products they ordered on
tmall Amazon was still accepting cash
from buyers upon delivery
Amazon also failed to understand what
appealed to Chinese Shoppers alibaba's
annual shopping Extravaganza singles day
was a huge hit Amazon didn't have a
counter as its annual discounted event
Prime day didn't exist yet the websites
of tmall and JD were also very colorful
and festive Amazon's website looked
rather Bland mirroring its other
homepages around the world Americans
prefer a minimalist design which is not
the case in China
it didn't help that Amazon China relied
on support from company headquarters in
Seattle and was slow to respond to
Market signals the company also turned
off Chinese sellers sellers were used to
paying two to five percent of their
sales to Alibaba in addition to paying
for ads to make their listings more
prominent however Amazon Executives were
not a fan of the advertising model and
instead charged sellers more 10 to 15
percent of sales so naturally they
flocked to Alibaba perhaps the biggest
mistake Jeff Bezos made in China was
that he failed to understand the
importance of forging good relations
with the government as bradstone writes
in his book about Amazon's growth called
Amazon Unbound
amazon.cn Executives from that time said
that Bezos was totally uninterested in
understanding the inner machinations of
the Chinese government cultivating ties
with Chinese leaders or using his
budding Fame to help Amazon's cause in
the country
Elon Musk didn't make the same mistake
when he opened Tesla's first factory in
China in 2019. musk has consistently
made an effort to woo Chinese officials
taking China's ambassador to the U.S for
a drive in a Model S plaid which the
Ambassador described as a smooth ride
it's unclear if they tried plaid mode
the fastest acceleration mode
on his weibo account musk frequently
Praises China's Space Program in
economic growth over the past three
decades the Chinese government has been
very supportive of Tesla in 2019 Tesla
became the first foreign automaker to
open an independent Factory in China
normally foreign car makers must team up
with a Chinese partner there apparently
was no excessive red tape as Tesla built
its Shanghai gigafactory in record time
going from Hermits to a finished plant
in just 168 working days or about six
months Tesla was one of 600 businesses
that the Chinese government deemed
important enough to open first amid the
lockdown in Shanghai in the spring of
2022 authorities arranged buses to
transport thousands of Tesla workers and
helped carry out the required
disinfection to curb the spread of
covid-19
musk has heaped Praise on Chinese
workers like in this interview with the
financial times
there's a lot of
strongly believe in in manufacturing and
and they will they go they'll they won't
just be writing the Midnight Oil they'll
be running the 3am oil
so
um they won't even leave the leave the
factory type of thing whereas in America
people are trying to avoid going to work
at all while Amazon China failed to get
close to Chinese consumers the
minimalist website being one example
musk has really tried to embrace Chinese
culture when he posted an ancient
Chinese poem about the importance of
getting along on a social media accounts
it went viral as people discussed what
he meant while Amazon China relied on
Seattle for support Tesla China is not
simply a branch of Tesla it's set up to
do original research and development
work Tesla opened a research center and
a separate data center in Shanghai in
2021 both are located near the
gigafactory musk's push for Ev
development conveniently aligns with
Chinese president XI jinping's pledge to
make China the leader in electric
Innovation Beijing aims to have 40
percent of vehicles sold in China the
electric by 2030 and Elon Musk is the
one person who can get them there it's
no wonder Beijing has been showering
Tesla with goodies such as cheap land
low interest rates and tax incentives
exempting Tesla cars from a 10 Purchase
Tax
within three years of opening Giga
Shanghai is now on track to produce at
least 900 000 cars a year if recent
monthly deliveries are any indication
and it's building another assembly line
near its existing plant which could add
another half a million model threes and
model wise a year according to Tesla
this will turn Shanghai into the world's
largest vehicle export Hub musk has
remained popular in China despite
deteriorating relations with the U.S
I've made a series of videos recently on
how Washington is trying to keep the
world's most critical chip technology
out of beijing's hands there's also the
issue of large-scale Human Rights abuses
in the country
so it's a delicate balance from us to
straddle the geopolitical fault lines
but Elon Musk needs China Chinese sales
helped Propel Tesla to its first full
year of profitability in 2020. 18 years
in the making and China needs Elon Musk
Chinese leaders have reportedly grown
frustrated with the performance of
domestic electric vehicle companies and
believe Tesla can lead the transition to
an electric future although Chinese
companies are starting to catch up in
the third quarter of 2022 byd sold 537
000 new energy Vehicles compared to
Tesla's 344 000 Vehicles however only
about half of byd's cars sold were fully
electric as new energy Vehicles also
include plug-in hybrids and hydrogen
fuel cell Vehicles so Tesla is still
ahead in all electric vehicle sales
for now Tesla is enjoying a fate that is
very different from Amazon's in the
world's most populous country
Tesla success lies in its ability to
innovate quickly as musk has said time
and time again what matters is the pace
of innovation well another company is
innovating an everyday product I wanted
a sleek and slim wallet so it was a
no-brainer for me to pick up an extra
wallet I actually picked one up before
the company reached out to me about
possibly sponsoring some of my videos I
especially like this model because
there's a spot for my air tag so I don't
have to worry about my wallet getting
lost regardless of what model you pick
up it's really easy to access all your
cards all you need to do is push this
button
extra also sent me a really cool light
carbon fiber wallet very very sleek and
minimalistic which I adore and to go
along with this wallet you can also pick
up a solar powered tracking card there
are a variety of extra wallets to choose
from if you go on their website they
even have a vegan leather smart wallet
if you'd like to try out an extra wallet
for yourself you can get 20 off by going
to the custom link in my description or
pin comment that's shop.exter.com
newsthink
shop.exter.com news thing thank you so
much for watching for newsthink I'm
Cindy Palm
foreign